game and a bit of discussion about some
of the rule changes for this season with
a real focus on player participation I
know you've all now seen the release
from the vote we took earlier today
regarding some changed approach to to
reinforcing the notion that we're in
82-game league and that's something that
uh Joe Dumars our Executive Vice
President of basketball operations has
been really reinforcing and I think
someone who has the credibility
to help the league frankly reset on that
issue and and just want to make the
point there that um
it's
it's a shared view by everyone in the
league it's not just coming from the
league office I think whether it's our
teams our Players Association individual
players I think there's an
acknowledgment across the league that we
need to return to that principle that
this is an 82-game league and that of
course doesn't mean that we're turning
the clock back that players are expected
to play through injuries or that players
frankly never need rest but I think it's
there's a statement of a principle that
if you're a healthy player in this
league that the expectation is that
you're going to play so I'm with that
happy to answer any questions you have
all right if you have any questions
raise your hand we'll bring a microphone
and as always name an affiliation who'd
like to start us off today
a very slow group we'll start with Mike
vorkenov in the second row
Mike borkanoff the athletic not used to
going first it's a lot of pressure
um with the with the new policy uh how
long had you been working on this how
much input was there for the employers
Association and do you uh worry that
this might be seen as kind of an over
interjection by the league into player
and team Health choices
um the in terms of how long we've been
working on it I'd say you with it with a
more serious Focus roughly in the last
year it became part of part of
collective bargaining I should say it's
the the player participation policy is
part of many steps we've taken whether
it's in the bargain agreement itself the
65 game
limit for eligibility for awards
creating different incentives for
players you know like the playing
tournament for example like the
in-season tournament to focus attention
on the regular season
uh but the policy itself I think it was
the Players Association
um was very much part of it
um we had extensive discussions with
them and then with individual groups of
players particularly veterans in the
league
um about
um how they thought we should be
approaching it and I
the last part of your question yes I do
worry about infringing on how a team
operates and
well we want to have state a strong
principle I would say at least initially
we're taking a somewhat light touch here
I think in in under the notion that
change will probably happen here
incrementally I think we'll State this
principle see how teams react and see if
more needs to be done but I I think most
importantly there's a sense from
all the different constituent groups in
the league that this is ultimately about
the fans
and that we've taken this too far I mean
this is an acknowledgment that it's
gotten away from us a bit and that
particularly I think when you see young
healthy players who are resting and it
becomes maybe even more notion of
stature around the league as opposed to
Absolute needed rest or it's just part
of being an NBA player that you rest on
certain days and that's what we're
trying to move away from
second row in the middle Vinnie Vince go
away y'all Sports Adam mostly what the
media has been told throughout this is
that the science determines whether a
player should sit or if he should play
depending on the schedule a lot of that
comes from the teams as opposed to the
players at least the perception is what
is the the pie on that from what the
team feels like is the best for them
versus The Players feeling like what's
best for them versus the league that has
a bigger picture to worry about honestly
that's what I had been told as well that
it was the science and I think it may be
why
the league
um didn't become involved maybe as
deeply as we should have earlier on and
part of the discussion today was about
the science and frankly the science is
inconclusive I think if there and I've
said this before if the science were
clearer that players should be resting
we would be favoring it and frankly I
beat
delivering the message to the fans even
that you want these players to rest at
certain times because that's going to
keep them healthier and performing at a
higher level and ensuring that they're
on the floor at critical Parts times in
the season what we talked about today is
that
the correlation putting aside cause a
causation isn't there even with players
who've participated in summer
competitions like World Cups and
Olympics they are not more likely to get
injured in that season we don't see any
statistical data suggesting that players
um increase their likelihood of getting
injured
as they go further along in the season
or even in back to backs which may
surprise people and I think
one of the things we're all learning
with data and science is not to take
anything for granted
see Sudafed most latest disclosure that
something we all thought was clearly
working maybe isn't but I think in the
case here that part of the commitment
here for from the league office is we
are putting together a group of Team
doctors and scientists and others and
trying to better understand it one thing
I want to make clear that the message to
our teams and players is not that rest
is never appropriate and realize there's
a bit of an art to this not just the
science and that's with the Hands-On
trainers and coaches who are talking to
players and saying how do you feel I'm
certainly not saying that's not relevant
I think at least in the first instance
in terms of this policy we're trying to
deal with some of the most egregious
examples where multiple star players for
example
healthy healthy all out on the same
night healthy healthy and I think that's
we're letting down the fans we're
letting down our partners by doing that
but at the same time we're stating a
principle in terms of an 82-game league
and saying let's all work together and I
think that's that was I thought
uh the best news coming out of this
policy whether it was with the Players
Association individual players or with
our teams over the last two days
everyone is acknowledging this is an
issue and that's an issue for the fans
so there was the adoption of the policy
was unanimous there was full support
from the player association
I think though people are also saying
well let's see what this means in
practice what does it mean when a league
doctor is coming in and separately
looking at a player's health I I do
think this will this policy will deal
with the more most egregious examples
and we'll go from there and I just think
lastly that
you know even though the teams are
highly competitive with each other they
shouldn't be competing when it comes to
health and the science of performance
and care for our players especially
since contracts have gotten shorter
players move from Team to teens and I
think
we're declaring also there's more to be
learned here and I think rather you know
in all seriousness like the Sudafed
example uh saying let's really not just
take for granted somebody's saying load
management well of course you need to
rest after this many days let's really
study it and understand it and see if
there are changes we need to make and it
may turn out you know a lot of the older
players by that I mean now at this point
retired players when I first became in
the league used to believe that they
were more likely to get injured if they
took nights off that it would they would
get out of rhythm and in some cases
maybe played fewer minutes but they
played and that's something we want to
look at as well second round